This video is so cute, but out of the
mouth of babes, listen to this wisdom.
The brain is telling me to say the
middle finger, and I don't want to do
the middle finger.
What?
Yeah, the brain is trying to say do the
middle finger. She's trying to say it. I
don't know what to do with her.
Oh, then just don't do it.
>> [clears throat]
>> I can't.
Yeah, you can.
What is wrong with you? I can't do it.
You better stop. You better not do it.
I changed my mind. Well, you better not.
>> Can you just take it out of my head?
Pray for me. You pray for yourself.
>> Do it in the bathroom.
You pray for yourself.
>> Jesus, please help me. Nanna, please get
this
middle finger out of my
brain.
Nanna, I don't want to learn about it
anymore. So, can you please help me?
Nanna, I don't want to learn the middle
finger anymore. I don't even know what
the middle finger does. Nanna, please
get this out of my middle finger. Nanna,
please, please. I'm very tired. I really
need you to get this out of my head.
Amen. Amen is right. She did what so
many Christians forget to do when we're
faced with trials and temptations. We
cannot overcome in our own strength. We
need to submit ourselves, surrender to
Christ, and ask him for help because
he's the only one that can give us the
power to have victory in our lives.